Reconciliación de hermanos enemigos es
lo que confirmaron este viernes Irán y
Arabia Saudita después de cuatro días de
conversaciones en Beijing
al final de las conversaciones Hemos
llegado a una conclusión para iniciar un
nuevo capítulo después de siete años de
ruptura de relaciones entre la República
islámica de Irán y árabes Saudita
teniendo en cuenta los asuntos de dos
países y la seguridad y el futuro de la
región para evitar la intromisión de los
estados extra regionales y occidentales
y la intromisión constante del régimen
sionista en la región
[Música]
se prevé que los dos países reactiven
Los acuerdos de seguridad y cooperación
comercial firmados en 1998 y 2001 a
rabia Saudita había roto relaciones con
Irán en 2016 tras el atentado contra su
embajada de Irán gesto iraní tras la
ejecución de un clérigochita en realidad
otra crisis importante tuvo lugar en
septiembre de 2019 cuando los Rebeldes
de Jiménez lanzaron un ataque contra dos
refinerías de una petrolera Estatal
saudí causando una reducción momentánea
del 50% de su producción de petróleo a
rabia Saudita había acusado a erran de
haber patrocinado estos ataques y
Naciones Unidas había confirmado que
varios misiles usados eran de origen
iraní este restablecimiento de lazos
diplomáticos podría alterar el
equilibrio de poder en Oriente medio
donde las dos potencias rivales se
enfrentan indirectamente en varios
terrenos como en yemen pero también en
Irak o en Líbano